i think it is a momentous moment in the
recent history of this island as joe was
explaining northern ireland has only
existed for 101 years but for the
duration of that time unionists have
been to the fore at stormont they've
held sway there no one really for a very
long time could have possibly envisaged
a day when an irish nationalist party
that doesn't even recognize northern
ireland's existence would be
in the position to nominate a first
minister that does two things it opens
up a huge debate about whether or not
there will be a power sharing government
going forward because of course michelle
o'neill from sinfin will need a unionist
partner in that government if it is to
proceed but the big question is what has
this done to the constitutional question
of northern ireland's place in the
united kingdom many believe it has
hastened the day when there will be a
referendum on northern ireland
potentially leaving the united kingdom
and reuniting with the rest of ireland
my report on this momentous day contains
flash photography from the beginning and
throughout
a new kind of politics for a new
generation
leadership had come to celebrate history
in the making the election of an irish
nationalist first minister
today ushers in a new era which i
believe presents us all with an
opportunity
to reimagine relationships in this
society on the basis of fairness on the
basis of equality and on the basis of
social justice
michelle o'neill knows the plates have
shifted that her victory could pave the
way to a referendum on irish unity
michelle a defining moment a new era
what does this mean for the
constitutional question of northern
ireland's place in the united kingdom
well i'm very pleased to report that
there is a very healthy conversation
already underway and i've always said
throughout the election campaign that
regardless of the outcome of the
election that conversation was going to
continue those of us that are for
unification will make that case i
encourage those that actually don't have
that perspective at this moment in time
to also enter into the conversation
let's have a healthy debate about what
our future looks like something that's
better for each and every one of us
sir jeffrey donaldson and his
predecessor were keen to present a
united front
[Applause]
the democratic unionists must now decide
if they'll accept this democratic
process but they're looking to dining
street what do you need from boris
johnson right now well to be honest
david what we need is action words are
good but what we need to happen is that
those words are followed up by action
decisive action by the government to
remove the irc border because we don't
believe it is acceptable or necessary to
have checks on goods moving within the
united kingdom
ira violence like the shankel bombing
saw schinfan banned from the airwaves at
the height of the troubles here the
elevation of its political wing is
difficult for victims but alan mcbride
whose wife died in the attack wants
northern ireland to move on
well they have a past and let's not
forget about that i mean they have come
from violence and from being
undemocratic to being democratic and for
to try to make the peace process work
and i think you have to recognize that
journey but that's not to say that you
just can you know forgive and forget and
move on and that's very very difficult
for people it is an undeniable truth
that northern ireland is a unique
complicated and often dysfunctional
place it really only works when
unionists and nationalists share power
as envisaged by the good friday
agreement
and when that doesn't happen
the people have no government
some think it's time for a new political
structure one that isn't dependent on
just two parties pulling together well
it's going to be difficult but the
alliance surge
puts the pressure on government to say
actually the system is no longer fit for
purpose and we should be reviewing it
because for the people of northern
ireland it shouldn't be a choice between
no government and bad government the
government should be there to deliver
for the people
michelle o'neill says she'll be at her
desk in stormont on monday ready to
tackle the bread and butter issues that
matter most
david blevins sky news macarons